good afternoon and welcome very welcome
to the 2017 Nobel Prize sermon in
Stockholm Sweden and you're not alone
watching several million people around
the globe are tuning in now to follow
this special moment it's of course
celebration of scientists and the author
that will soon enter this stage but more
than that it's a celebration of science
itself as was the wish of Alfred Nobel
the Swedish inventor that founded the
prize through his will before died in
1896 1901 was the first Nobel Prize to
be handed out and ever since it is a
tradition on this day the 10th of
December the anniversary of Alfred
Nobel's death and the ceremony is held
here in the concert hall of Stockholm
afterwards time for the big banquet
which ends with dancing party for some
laureates all night long but first they
have to receive that prize it will be
delivered from the hands of his majesty
the king of Sweden kinko Gustav he
together with parts of his family will
take place to the right on on the stage
here in the golden chairs that we see
and to the left in the red chairs we
will have this year's laureates at the
center of it all in the background we
see the portrait bust of Alfred Nobel
there will be presentation speeches
about the year's
prizes before an audience of nearly
1,600 guests that are gathered here this
afternoon
each laureate has to write to an
official party of 14 members of family
and friends the rest of the people in
the audience are people related to the
world of science representatives of the
price awarding institutions members of
the Swiss government in Parliament and
the diplomatic courts and we are
awaiting the royal family and the Nobel
laureates to arrive to the tune of the
Swedish royal anthem
we also have a number of two previous
laureates present in the audience they
amongst other designated scientific
figures are the ones allowed to nominate
new laureates perhaps some of their
favorites are the ones about to enter
the stage the chairman of the board of
the Nobel foundation professor called
Henry killed in will hold an opening
address and the ceremony will be framed
by brief musical interludes performed by
the Stockholm Willimantic Orchestra the
audience is standing up in honor of the
royal family
entering soon and of course the Nobel
laureates and perhaps one might say in
honor of this celebration of science
itself which is truly at the heart of
the Nobel Prize
now that almost all of the royal family
has entered it's time for the switch
role anthem to be played
Queen Silvia this my lucky dress king
carl gustav Crown Princess Victoria and
Prince Daniel
in blue Crown Princess Victoria a now
speech by Professor Callaghan Raquel
Dean chairman of the board of the Nobel
Foundation
so that was the second movement alla
siciliana from Gaelic symphony by Amy
Beach soon who will hear the speech now
entering this year's laureates
everyone's standing up for
physics laureates Orion advice Tyra
bearish and Kip Thorne followed by
chemistry laureate selectable share
working Frank Richard Henderson
here we see literature laureate Kazuo
Ishiguro
kind of eyes together a bearish thought
checked people shame now we're in
chemistry and you're confront and a
third chemistry laureates Richard Hanson
medicine or physiology this year's
laureates on Geoffrey Howe Michael Ross
Bosch and Michael Young sitting next to
him getting a glimpse of this your Royal
Highnesses esteemed Nobel laureates
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
Nobel foundation it's a great pleasure
for me to welcome you to this year's
Nobel Prize award ceremony in particular
I would like to wish the Nobel laureates
and their families
welcome to this ceremony earlier today
in Oslo the international campaign to
abolish nuclear weapons
I can was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
for its work to draw attention to the
catastrophic humanitarian consequences
or any use of nuclear weapons and for
its groundbreaking efforts to achieve a
treaty based provision of such weapons
today we are celebrating this year's
Nobel laureates
and their outstanding achievements in
science literature and peace we are also
honoring the values the Nobel Prize
stands for enlightenment human humanism
and peaceful coexistence Alfred Nobel
dreamed of a better world and in many
ways the world has become a better place
since he wrote his will in the late 19th
century thanks to scientific cultural
and economic developments more people
had the opportunity to fulfill
themselves and to live long and rich
lives scientific achievements have not
only made new technologies possible they
have also given us a deeper
understanding how everything in our
universe functions from the stars to the
cells in our bodies cultural advances
has lessened the impact of prejudice and
tradition economic growth has laid the
groundwork for take
logical and social progress as well as
material wealth
we now have societies where people are
able to live the life they desire to a
degree the world has never seen before
however today we are seeing accumulation
of new threats against further possible
post positive developments science and
the quest for knowledge shall be in
questioned even in parts of the world
when they have been taken for granted
facts knowledge and rational thinking
are being challenged by alternative
facts untruthful statements and
irresponsible actions cross-border trade
and cooperation are being resisted
fundamental human rights are being
ignored one upsetting example being the
treatment of the Rohingyas in Myanmar
all too many people are living under a
constant threat of violence the values
expressed in Alfred Nobel's will are
still relevant today humanistic values
critical thinking the search for
scientific facts and true knowledge must
be the basis in our actions and
decisions both in our private lives and
in politics and business Alfred Nobel
understood the power of good examples in
many ways Nobel laureates become role
models and sources of inspiration in the
spirit of Alfred Nobel we should all
stand up to the challenge of our times
and try to bring about change in times
like this schools are more important
than ever
some say that in the post truth era the
focus should be on teaching pupils how
to be critical about sources of
information this is important in the
label but in addition young people need
solid knowledge and high-quality
education to be able to contribute to
the progress and improvement of our
society they need to learn how to meet
each other
Cashion to respect different views and
to find ways of jointly arriving at
sensible conclusions being a teacher is
an important task one of the most
important in our society today time
after time when the bell laureates are
asked about what have been the vital
influences in their lives the research
and their success they recall the
teacher who encouraged them to excel we
want to contribute on a small scale by
strengthening the position of teachers
and by promoting exchange between
teachers from different cultures and
different countries for this purpose we
have launched a new forum this year the
noble teacher summit and for the very
first time we brought this year's prize
awarded achievements to classrooms
around the world by producing
downloadable Nobel Prize lessons within
24 hours of the prize announcements the
fascinating stories of the mouth nine
hundred and twenty three Nobel laureates
formed the basis for our many outreach
activities which engage audiences in
Stockholm Oslo and around the world the
plant Nobel Center in Stockholm will be
a platform with education knowledge and
critical thinking at its heart where the
major challenges of tomorrow will be
discussed here school pupils university
students scientists and visitors from
all over the world will be inspired by
the Nobel laureates
and their accomplishments for the great
greatest benefits to mankind I would
like to conclude by quoting Nobel
laureate Roger Kornberg in the world
beset by irrational influences often
with devastating consequences the Nobel
Prize call attention to the triumph of
Reason your Majesties your Royal
Highnesses esteem Nobel laureates ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much
professor karl-henrik building chairman
of the board of Nobel Foundation said
that and here we see some of the nearly
sixteen hundred guests here today and
now time to present the Nobel Prize in
Physics soon it's time for that the
first another musical
this was a piece from the Gaelic
symphony by Amy Beach who was the first
successful American female composer of
large-scale art music premiered in 1896
in Boston actually the same year as
Alton the Bell died it was the first
symphony composed and published by an
American woman and now time for the
physics prize and a presentation at
presentation speech by Professor Olga
Bolton a member of the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences Your Majesty
Majesty's Royal Highnesses esteemed
laureates ladies and gentlemen Tim
Crafton gravitation is the weakest force
we know yet it is the force that keeps
our feet on the ground
why do you steam craft in some yeardley
the term it determines the orbits of the
planets around us Suns governs the
violent encounters the 2017 Nobel Prize
in Physics honors the discovery that
reflects this apparent discord between
strength and weakness in a subtle way
observation of an incredibly weak
distortion of space to a passing
gravitational wave created in a
momentous collision between two black
holes in a faraway galaxy for income a
dream about 1.3 billion years ago at a
time when the first multicellular life
emerged on earth two black holes with
masses close to 30 times that of our Sun
entered the final stages of a deadly
battle
whurling finally at half the speed of
light they collided and merged an event
which sent gravitational waves speeding
through space and time carrying
information on what had just ever since
then the ways have travelled through the
universe sweeping through the earth on
September 14 2015 when they were
discovered by the newly commissioned
twin detectors of the laser
interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory designed to notice the
tiniest vibrations this was the first
time ever that a passing gravitational
wave had been directly observed on earth
this amazing observation resents the
dawn of a new era opening up new vistas
for astronomy and bringing about new
possibilities to study gravitation close
to black holes where it is
gravitational waves were predicted about
hundred years ago in the framework of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
which connects gravitation with the
geometry of space-time they arise as
ripples in space-time whenever objects
accelerate traveling outward from the
source as ever week when gravitational
waves reached the earth they stretch and
squeeze space by this by the tiniest
amount far too small to be detected by
human senses nevertheless the team of
scientists led by this year's Nobel
laureate succeeded in overcoming the
challenge constructing detectors called
laser interferometers capable of
measuring the microscopic distortions
billions of times smaller than the
thickness of the strand of spider spider
silk in the distance between two mirrors
these interferometers use laser split
along two arms each four kilometers long
the mirrors at each end reflect the
light back to a point where the light
the resulting light weight is channel 2
detector where a pattern of shadow
passing gravitational wave stretches one
of the arms and compresses the other
causing the pattern to shift Manute li
which is what the scientists to exclude
local disturbances like passing trucks a
tiny earthquakes causing two instruments
to vibrate the observatory comprises two
identical detectors of opposite sides of
the american continents separated by
about three thousand kilometers
continent on it off stun rocketry to
sinsa-dong yet on September the 14th of
nine fifty detectors registered almost
identical signals from the passing way
with less than seven milliseconds this
not only confirmed the signal but
allowed localization of its source
within an arc on the southern skies the
first direct observation of a
gravitational wave is in more than one
sense an earth-shaking discovery a
breakthrough which has been followed by
additional significant observations in
opens anticipated opportunities to
explore hitherto invisible parts of the
universe where according to the renowned
Stroman a Carl Sagan something
incredible is Professor vice professor
barish professor Thorne you have been
awarded the 2017 Nobel Prize for Physics
for your decisive contributions to the
detector of the laser interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory and for
the observation of gravitational waves
on behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy
of Sciences it's my honor and my great
pleasure to convey to you our warmest
congratulations I now ask you to step
forward to receive your Nobel prizes
from the hands of His Majesty the King
first Reiner vice born in Germany
affiliated to MIT in the United States
of America
receiving the diploma are the medal from
the hands of His Majesty the King
of the family
and France and so time for Barry bearish
or for born in the United States
associated to Caltech California
and Kip Thorne also American who is
affiliated with Celtic in the United
States
from gravitational waves to chemistry
it's time for presentation by Professor
Peter Brzezinski a member of the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences yet despite
that Majesty's Royal Highnesses and
gentlemen the heart of accuracy what
lovely music we have been hearing
flowing from the choir you know ears
electrical signals are being generated
in nerve cells are activated and
molecules causing pleasure and are
released and bound to their receptors
these molecules are conducted inside the
cells out of reach of our senses and
even so these processes allow us to hear
a long-held dream we were able to dive
into a cell and see the molecule is the
core of what we call life then what
molecules are small if we were able to
enlarge yours
yes sensory organs to the size of this
hole hundreds of protein molecules would
fit into each coma in the program you're
holding in your hand the electron
electron microscope this instrument was
first invented nearly 100 years ago but
it would take up in the microscopes
examine biological samples in an
electron microscope they need molecules
in ourselves however are surrounded by
water that forms when it freezes these
electrons lose their way in the crystal
labyrinth and the images come out black
freezing water without forming ice
crystals
thought to be impossible Jacques
Cousteau she moved to Heidelberg just
out of pure curiosity he wanted to do
something that was considered impossible
something that even lack practical
application yet how would one write
grant proposal for such a project
perfected who would be willing to
finance it in the early nineteen
eighties want a bush a flash-frozen
water at minus 200 degrees Celsius he
gazed at this water was both liquid and
solid at the same time we call this
stage people che had created a window
into the world at around the same time
starting a microorganism living in salt
saturated this organism small well
organized solar collectors made from
protein molecules on it in 1990 after
having salt our best electron
microscopes no Henderson was able to
show the structure and it's solar
collectors in doing so at the microscope
provide detailed structures of the
thousands of molecules hiding these
molecules in microscope images can be
compared to finding a shadow of a bird
in the weak glow of the moon you are
welcome Frank succeeded in developing
methods that made it possible to find
this thing Molecular shadows indirect
painter the challenge was tend to
determine how the molecule is a position
of in relation to each other
laplacian - hold on deliver under after
more than ten years Frank finally was
able to present sharp three-dimensional
model strange
Oh molecules Goku but see another in
recent years advances have come quickly
the scientific literature describes the
cursor the progress as an ongoing
revolution those of you in the front row
not to be concerned however within
science revolutions or in nature some
say some Liga Sara it is a miracle I
think that we now can look into
ourselves
thereby shrinking our senses men but he
quoted famous killers and some October
and from voxi chemist
Mira post sometimes occur but one has to
work terribly hard for them
Jacques de Bhushan he work in Frank and
Richard Henderson your world has led to
the development of cryo-electron
microscopy for the high-resolution
structure determination of biomolecules
in solution that is a truly great
achievement a truly great achievement on
behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences I wish to convey to you our
warmest congratulations may I now ask
you to step forward and receive your
Nobel prizes from the hands of His
Majesty the King
first ass is rejected Boucher born in
Switzerland at the University of
Lausanne shaken hands with king carl
gustav of sweden and receiving his nobel
diploma and medal the bell diplomas and
the medals will be taken care of for the
Nobel laureates so they don't lose it
during the banquet basket is about to
begin later this evening and now you're
working Frank born in Germany and at the
time of the announcement it was
associated with the Columbia University
in the United States
Carroll Saginaw we sold out and here is
the third chemistry laureate Richard
Henderson born in Scotland associated
with Cambridge in the night in United
Kingdom
now time for another musical interlude
by johann sebastian bach soprano kamila
chilling on trumpet you were king Magnus
stop on Philharmonic Orchestra
this aria from cantata number 51 by
johann sebastian bach was before by the
second harmonic orchestra at the Battle
of to Anika nedeau one of the world's
most prominent young conductors and
soloists soprano kamila chilling in our
time before is this your only Highnesses
esteemed Nobel laureates ladies and
gentlemen the medicine prize Phileas
Fogg the main character in Jules Verne's
acclaimed novel around the world in 80
days could not have suffered from jet
lag during history despite crossing
multiple time zones his body had plenty
of time more than three days per
timezone to get adjusted to the time
differences encounter along his journey
today in the era of jet travel we can
cross several time zones in only a few
hours but our bodies suffer as they
struggled to adapt to the new time our
destination many our foreign guests this
evening are surely experiencing this now
why can't our physiology adult more
rapidly what keeps it behind our
physiology is regulated by an internal
clock that generates daily rhythms know
about circadian from the Latin circadian
meaning around one day circadian rhythms
are ancient and exist in all forms of
life life on Earth is adapted to the
rotation or a planet and the internal
clock anticipates day/night cycles
helping organisms optimize their
physiology and their behavior although
the existence of a biological clock has
been known for nearly a century only
recently have we began to understand
what is it made of and how it keeps
ticking our story begins in 1729 when
french astronomer jean jacques de Marana
took a mimosa plant which leaves her
open during the day but closed at night
and place it in constant
darkness he observed that the Leafs
still open and closed rhythmically at
the appropriate time suggesting an
endogenous origin of the daily rhythm
physiology is controlled by genes and
the biological clock is no exception
in 1971 Seymour Benzer and Ron Konopka
isolated mutant flies that had
alterations in their normal 24-hour
cycle of activity 15 years later jeffrey
hall and michael rosebush working
together at Brandeis University in
Massachusetts and Michael yang at
Rockefeller University in New York
isolated that mutated gene called period
as instrumental as these walls however
the isolation of the period gene did not
tell very much about the mechanism of
the biological clock he was a remarkable
series of discoveries made early 1990s
by these years Nobel laureates that
finally elucidated how our biological
clock ticks the basic principle first
proposed by Jeffery Hall and Michael
rosebush is deceptively simple the
period gene produces a protein that
accumulates in the cell and after
reaching a certain level blocks the gene
and hands its own production as the
protein levels subside the gene becomes
active again and the cycle resumed as
many things in biology however the devil
is in the details as it was still
unclear how the period protein can be
stabilized long enough and then entered
the cell nucleus to inhibit its own
production
Michael yang discovered two additional
genes
he named in timeless and double time the
corner material and together contribute
to the generation of robust oscillations
of approximately 24 hours the discomfort
of
headline is evidence of the strength of
our biological clock as it takes time
for the machinery to readjust to the
sudden change in environmental
conditions although sunlight is cars
this time of year in Stockholm the good
news is that food is also strong reset
in stimulus so the banquet that follows
after the ceremony will surely helps to
were adjusting our gender clocks the
2017 Nobel laureates have uncovered a
mechanism control in a truly fundamental
process in Physiology how our cells and
bodies keep time such timekeeping is
essential for adaptation and has
important implications from human health
no just yet luck but also the incidence
of chronic syndromes such as cancer
metabolic and sleep disorders and
several neurological conditions
professors Hall rosebush and yang you're
brilliant studies have sold one of the
great hassles in Physiology your
discovery seven ruble decoction wheels
of the biological clock an essential
mechanism for the survival of life on
our planet on behalf of the Nobel
assembly are the Karolinska Institute I
wish to convey to you our warmest
congratulations may I now ask that you
step forward to receive the Nobel Prize
from the hands of His Majesty the King
was professor Carlos Ibanez member of
the Nobel Committee for Physiology or
medicine speaking holding the
presentation speech of the medicine
prize first to receive it is Jeffrey
hall
you
born in the United States professor
emeritus at the University of Maine
Michael Ross Bosch Osbourne United
States American related with the
Brandeis University
you see his wife Nadia coverage to the
farmers right here and finally Michael
Young who is affiliated with the
Rockefeller University get the ball and
Michael Ross Bosh having worked together
very tightly and also as France and
Michael Young with his team
both teams racing to the same discovery
the competition with each other now on
the state together finally receiving
this recognition together fine moment
this day on the 10th of December for
them and for medic medical science
now some more music
leavis patient by Erich Wolfgang
Korngold and sung by soprano kamila
chilling now it's time for this is
literature price and a speech by
professor surah darkness who is the
Permanent Secretary of the Swedish
Academy that shows so if you Guru SDC is
laureate yes my after Majesty's Royal
Highnesses another man Okada
ladies and gentlemen soon within a few
pages the main character receives a
present
honeymoon is young and wrapping this
present you find several sheets of legs
not Eric after dark he takes away page
after page played a joke on him finally
unpack his old leather case the
magnifying has no bearing on the
provides us with an e-learning page of
the paged never even ripped by a desire
to discover what is and finally opening
you'll see two behind ourselves a
musician the magnifying glass
dr issue guru this is if you could
escape to the reader and optical device
to help us human beings
our selves for sin forever submerged as
we are in the violent history emeritus
of issue going to read issue years to
entra statistic world that is gloriously
unpretentious stringed target
boudreaux's is controlling restrained
and exact even that is legal and deal of
house stool here and there in Nice is
great the susi all Elizabeth's regular
on one hand the ordinary social life for
the up Sudha some calf just be a ghost
some moron who instability till an
insect
I've been Tarleton into the absurd like
Franz Kafka stories what the student of
a dog and some belly a done messed
around are Amana remainder of the day
which is probably the most peach famous
story woman in school tells the story of
an English Butler on his way to an old
friend you know will be a thought at all
before we know it we are sliding down
into the abdomen saguru Savard EMT Laura
the world of issue is a world without
heroes but also know his writing comes
out of the realistic 19th century
tradition she tradition with innovators
of his Jane Austen Charles figures
Bronte and George this was when the
novel opened its window onto the
quotidian world
yogoro too is an innovator always taking
risks with every new book he
investigates a new genre mix with
elements of the detective story science
fiction myth Romano's fungsten the
window of the night novel has always
been has whined it what about early 20th
century modernism did server is hard to
imagine issues without and others who
have explored new literary terrain in
particular human consciousness
so come on plus eerie music this is
where to situate it on the literary map
something yet this is only background
Felicia gore is characterized by
striking integrity I'm teetering this
viewpoint is his alone in city regions
understand theringer writes about
different kinds of people
a Japanese mother whose daughter
committed suicide in the years of the
Second World War a pianist from what do
these stories have in common rule the
reader must search for the root has each
in some way inquire into the
relationship between present and past we
call this relationship death the whole
longer tolerable mean perfect there is
some pleuritis such as post and wolf
attempt to salvage the past Ishiguro's
persist
how many journeys with these stories as
as though they were diving bells making
discoveries in democracy the bubble
explodes in detail we interact with the
past and what we as individuals
communities societies also must forget
in order survive at all ferret arms
cannot believe them
dear mister Ishiguro it is my great
pleasure to convey to you the warm
congratulations of the Swedish Academy
and to ask you to receive from the hands
of His Majesty the King the Nobel Prize
for Literature British novelist as we
should goro born in Japan in Nagasaki he
moved to England in the 1960s when he
was 5 years old
as you heard he is considered one of the
most celebrated contemporary fiction
authors in the english-speaking world
and now also a Nobel laureates
for saving 2017 years frogs
wonderful approaches to mr. Shapiro
well read by several of the other Nobel
laureates this year
congratulation what a appropriate title
of next musical interlude by the limpid
rebellion
congratulation from Joseph flowers by
Swedish national romantic composer Dylan
at the front angle leading us up to the
Sweden central bank's Prize in Economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel and
the presentation speech by Professor
Matt Majesty's Royal Highnesses were in
the year
17:26 something absolutely terrible
happen rather athenry castle in the
southeast corner of Scotland and a three
year old boy was kidnapped by a group of
drifters passing through the area not
from his parents sent out an alarm and
soon after a woman was spotted in
vicinity carrying the boy was rescued
and happily reunited with his family
what to do if that rescue had not
occurred we might not be standing here
today the boy would not show the graphic
Alaska and a member of the fabled Royal
Society Smith as the boy was cool he's
indeed known as one of the great
thinkers of the enlightened and is
widely recognized as a founder of modern
economics miss Gibb Adam Smith wrote two
important Wealth of Nations published in
1776 explains how markets create
economic welfare and introduced the idea
that an invisible hand guide firms
owners were motivated solely by the
self-interested pursuit of profit
maximization to produce exactly those
goods that households demand his other
great work the Theory of Moral
Sentiments was published 17 years set
out to explain the existence of morals
and norms in society
he described human behavior as a
struggle between our mission focused on
immediate satisfaction long-term or
again
rational self and hack camp enforced
according to Smith the struggle between
these opposing internal forces makes us
a fascinating between stupidity wisdom
impulsivity and selfishness and concern
for others morals and norms help our
impartial spectator keep our passions in
check and unnecessary well these two
monumental works provide two very
different views of human behavior and
indeed the tension between them has been
evident in economic research for the
last we see that individuals act
irrationally and myopically leading many
to make decisions that do not serve them
work on the other hand smaller forces
may diminish the role that these
individual long-term agents are
completely rational and they forced
laughter either to dr. Beeler began his
career as a researcher in the late 70s
that rational paradigm have recently
made great advances and created
frameworks that are still important for
understanding markets organizations
contracts and negotiation as a doctoral
student however hater observed that most
including prominent economists did not
behave as the rational agents of
economic theory and started collecting
anomalies in a crucial moment he
realized that insights from cognitive
psychology could be used to shed light
on many sub speedy agents from rational
behavior time was drive to derive new
theories and hypotheses that were better
grounded in human psychology failures to
color the papers who planner do a model
for limited self-control builds on the
conflict between our planning and
impulsive self and Kant among other
things be used to analyze how to improve
people's savers behavior shows how
people's preferences for fairness can
stop firms from raising prices and cause
shortage of enjoyment his theory of
mental accounting
how limited cognition makes use simple
rules of thumbs when making financial
decisions leading to systematic patterns
and biases outside of academia Vedas
work has had a significant impact on
real-world policymaking not Dilys in the
area of pension program design his idea
of nudging people to save more has
helped create literally billions of
dollars of retirement world filled with
people throughout the world
these programs are clear examples of how
aim sites from behavioral economics can
help individuals make better economic
decisions your work on the consequences
of bounded rationality limited self
control and people's sense of fairness
has brought insights from psychology
from the fringe of economics so it's
very Center your research has been
crucial in building the new field of
behavioral economics it has in foreign
public policy unified social science and
finally liberated Adam Smith it's an
honor and a privilege to convey to you
on behalf of the Royal Swedish Academy
of Sciences our warmest congratulations
I now ask you to receive your prize from
His Majesty the King Richard Thaler
a portal figure within the field of
behavioral economics now receiving his
Nobel Prize one might say that the 2002
prize to Daniel Kenneth Kahneman was the
first of this fine recognition of how
one successfully can bring psychology
into economics in our 2017 it's time for
mr.
was taken by sentiments here the strong
moment for him of course
the tears are not far away for mr.
Griffith paler and now
we have the Swedish national anthem
now that the queen of Sheba's festivity
march from the prodigal son by google
ambient which traditionally is played
while the guests are the beginning with
Queen Silvia King Hall Gustav Crown
Princess Victoria in blue with a prince
first ones to leave the concert hall of
Stockholm heading towards the city hall
where the banquet is held is Prince
Philip and his business is superior and
more members of the Swedish royal family
sitting in front row here together
together with other prominent guests
amongst others the prime minister of
Sweden and parts of the government and
political parties representatives from
the academic organizations
and have been awarding of selecting this
year's laureates
the chairman of the Nobel foundation
call Chanukah pin is heading the
congratulation to her by the Nobel
laureates thank you very much for
joining the 2017 Nobel Prize ceremony
you